hey guys mark from GameSpot here and I'm
here today to talk to you about the
wonders of PC gaming or rather how you
can cast off the shackles of the closed
proprietary systems of the PlayStation 4
and Xbox one and give yourself access to
a bigger cheaper and more eclectic
library of games now I know what you're
thinking
yeah sure my PC gaming is great and all
the consoles are way cheaper than a
decent gaming PC STFU dude well that's
what we're here today to put to the test
is it possible to build a gaming PC for
the same price as an Xbox one which
costs around five hundred and fifty
dollars when you include US sales tax
and if so will it run games as well or
given that the Xbox one can't even
muster a full 1080p 64 the lights of
titanfall maybe even run them better I'm
going to be taking on the Xbox one and
ps4 with an AMD based PC while my
esteemed colleague piece of brain will
be doing the same thing with Intel and
NVIDIA parts to help you see which will
give you the most bang for your buck
check out the full article on GameSpot
to see how his machine turned out but
for now let's get this show on the road
and see what parts I've chosen to go
into this potentially console beating
AMD based PC one of the main
disadvantages of building your own
budget PC versus buying a pre-built one
is the cost of a Windows license or big
companies like Dell and HP cheaply
bundle windows with their computers
sadly we're stuck with $100 price tag
for the OS sure you could go steam OS
for free but there just aren't enough
games on it right now
which makes the latest and most
supported version of Windows Windows 8.1
the way to go I got a sweet deal for a
legit copy of Windows for $70 via eBay
but use caution with the auction site
there are some total dealers out there
if you're going to build a budget PC
than AMD CPUs are the logical choice
particularly when it comes down to sheer
value for money at first I thought it
wise to go for one of AMD's a series ap
use which combines a CPU and GPU onto a
single chip but they're pricey and
performance isn't as good as when using
a dedicated GPU instead I went for AMD's
FX
300 fish Recife you based on the
Piledriver architecture it still can't
quite keep up with the best I 5s and I
seventh of the world but it's close
and it'll smoke the costlier dual core
i3 s thanks to his decent clock speed
and six cores for the GPU I went with
AMD's older but still excellent and
brilliantly overclockable Radeon HD 7850
in fact the recently released r7 265 is
just a rebranded version of the card
with a slight clock speed bump and with
retailers clearing out stock to make way
for the 265 you can pick up a 7850 for
just over a hundred bucks from retailers
like Newegg i overthought this one to
1050 megahertz and memories of 1450
megahertz
with little effort putting the GPU
squarely in 7873 territory with the two
most important components selected the
rest are easy to pick out based on the
amount of cash I had left for the
motherboard I went with Asus is casually
named m5 a 7/8 L - M / USB 3 a.m. 3 +
which is based on the 760 G chipset in a
micro ATX form factor
it lacks niceties such as PCI Express
3.0 and SATA 6 but it does feature USB 3
as well as a sis's famed motherboard
reliability making it great value at
around $50 power comes courtesy of an 80
plus rated EVGA 500 watt PSU at $45 some
might consider that overkill but it
gives us Headroom for future upgrades
and overclocking and you never skimp on
the PSU unless you like the thought of
potentially frying your shiny new
components storage is handled by 500
gigabyte Seagate Drive at around 50
bucks which is a fast 7200 rpm model and
that should give us a relatively good
amount of storage with games Ram comes
in the form of a stick of Kingston
HyperX XMP blue series running at 1600
megahertz budget constraints me like it
only stretched to 4 gigabytes at around
40 bucks but if you've got a few extra
bucks to plow into your PC here's where
I suggest you spend it and pick up eight
gigabytes to house the components I went
with factors call one hundred case it's
a case I've used before on
PC builds and at less than $40 is one of
the cheapest micro ATX cases out there
or at least one of the cheapest that
doesn't look completely terrible and
isn't a total pain to work inside plus
it's got some nice airflow features with
120 millimeter fan in the front space
for a 92 millimeter in the back a
removable side mounted hard disk tray
and the option to add another hundred 20
mil fan to the side of the case the
total cost just a smidge over the target
at five hundred and sixty six dollars
and sixteen cents was that extra 16
bucks worth it well let's put this
sucker together and find out
[Music]
so here she is the finished article now
there's not a lot of cable management
options in the core 1000 but cheap
doesn't have to mean untidy by using one
of the five and a half inch drive bays
to hide the cables we can still get
something that's relatively clean
and that gives us good airflow but
enough of the fluff let's get Windows on
this bad boy and benchmark us some games
mech base shooter titanfall runs and a
heavily modified version of valves
Source engine which isn't the most
demanding of game engines despite that
the Xbox one famously only runs the
gamer 792p whereas the AMD rig has no
trouble running it at its higher
settings at 1080p and with two times
multi sampling anti-aliasing on and a
locked at 60 frames per second
battlefield 4 is a much more graphically
demanding shooter on ps4 it runs at 1600
by 900 whereas the Xbox one runs it at
720p using the high settings preset at
1080p with anti-aliasing off the AMD rig
pushes around 72 frames per second on
average and still looks the business
cranking it to ultra with two times
multi sampling anti aliasing we see a
noticeable drop in framerate at 1080p to
around 42 frames per second which makes
it still very playable if you're willing
to drop down to the ps4 1600 by 900
resolution you'll get some very slick
visuals and an easily locked 60 frames
per second Assassin's Creed 4 is another
demanding title one that the Xbox one
only pushes at 900 P while the ps4
manages a full and deliciously sweet
1080p both run at only 30 frames per
second though at high settings at 1080p
with FX AAA on the AMD Rig boasts a
frame rate of around 47 frames per
second interestingly bumping up to very
high with FXAA didn't massively affect
the frame rate dropping it down slightly
to 42 frames per second a lock 30 frames
per second at the highest settings is
possible then giving you a better
looking experience than on the next-gen
consoles
based on Unreal Engine three thief was
never going to present too much of an
issue quite many other games the Xbox
one version is only rendered at 900p
while the ps4 runs at 1080p with
everything turned on to the higher
settings with the exception of super
sampling anti-aliasing which remained
off the AMD Rig pushed 87 frames per
second on average making a lock 60
absolutely no trouble at all
so there you have it folks is it
possible to build a gaming PC on a
next-gen budget absolutely there are
some compromises to be made along the
way and if you can stretch to an extra
$100 or so you'll have a PC that I'll
keep you gaming for some time more
Ramsay obvious choice it doesn't cost
much to bump it up to 8 gigabytes and
the less time the PT has to spend
thrashing the hard drive for a swap file
the better an extra $70 towards an r2 17
GPU would be a wise decision too it's
good value and overclocks extremely well
putting it firmly in the high end GPU
segment for just a fraction of the cost
there's also the option of an SSD for a
more responsive feel and aftermarket
cooler for CPU overclocking and a nicer
looking case but they're not essential
the fact is though instead of buying an
Xbox one or even a ps4 you can build
yourself a great gaming PC that will run
games even better than those consoles do
currently and you'll have access to a
vast cheaper library of games via
services like Steam or you'll find
triple-a releases indie gems and free to
play games like dota 2 that you simply
can't get on a console and hey if you
really want to you can hook up a
controller plug it into your TV and kick
back on the sofa in your living room too
that's it from me but be sure to check
out Pete's video to see how he got on
with his Intel and NVIDIA based PC and
check out the full article over on
GameSpot see you next time
you